ORDER.
WE HAVE --
LET ME LET ME SAY THE WELCOME
BACK FOR THE START OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY SESSION.
FOR THIS ONE DAY BEFORE WE
ADJOURN UNTIL JANUARY LET ME
START BY WELCOMING.
OUR NEWEST MEMBER SANDING GROWTH
SENATOR STANDING GROW.
AND OF COURSE AS WE JUST
WITNESSED WE WANT TO WELCOME OUR
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE.
WHO WILL BE JOINING US
[inaudible]
AND ACTUALLY LEADING.
US THROUGH ALL OF THIS IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE WE HAVE A FAIRLY
SHORT AGENDA TODAY --
SO LET ME JUST THE I HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AS WERE
HERE.
WE HAVE OUR ITEM NUMBER ONE
ADOPT THE HOLIDAY SCHEDULE --
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN WHILE THERE
MAY BE SOME DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT FROM OUR SECRETARY.
YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T CALL THE ROLE
SO BEFORE I GO TO YEAH I SHOULD
BACK UP HAVEN'T FORGOTTEN --
GIVEN HOW OFTEN WE HAVE THESE
RULES COMMITTEE MEETINGS I
SHOULD NOT HAVE FORGOTTEN --
CALL THE ROLL MADAM SECRETARY
SENATORS GROWTH.
GROWTH HERE MINING MINING HERE
ROUGH ROUGH HERE WELCOME
PRESIDENT WILL CURE ATKINS HERE
I CAN SEE HERE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY SO WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM GOING BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER --
ONE AS I UNDERSTAND IT WHILE WE
MAY HAVE.
A DIFFERENCE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
AS IT RELATES TO OUR DECEMBER
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY FIFTH IT
DOESN'T INTERFERE WITH ARE
CONDUCTING A BUSINESS SO WE CAN
GO AHEAD.
AND I MOVED AND ADOPT THE
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN SO I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU OF MOTION HAS
BEEN MADE --
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS GROWTH.
GROVE I MINING MINING I ROUGH
ROSS I WILL GO ON WILL GUY AT
CAN SIGN A CONCISE.
AND I'M GONNA GO AHEAD ND JUMP
TO ITEM THREE THE JOINT
COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS.
ARE AND SUBCOMMITTEE
RATIFICATIONS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH I THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY
TAKE TOGETHER I HAVE NOT
RECEIVED.
ANY CONCERN AND THAT WOULD
APPOINT ITEM WHAT A POINT
SENATOR MITCHELL AS CHAIR
SENATORS BATES LARA MINING.
NIELSEN PAY AND SKINNER AND
STONE AS MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
FILLING ALL THE VACANCIES.
BECAUSE WE HAVE WORK TO DO
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THIS YEAR
IN TERMS OF REPLACING OUR LA --
POSITION.
IN JANUARY IT WOULD BE MY
INTENTION TO REPLACE MR LARA BUT
GIVEN THAT THE WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND HE'S BEEN.
PART OF THIS PROCESS --
IN DISCUSSING IT WITH THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER WE SEE NO
REASON NOT TO HAVE THIS MOVE
FORWARD --
SO THAT WE GET THAT WORK DONE SO
THAT WOULD EXPLAIN JOINT
COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE AND FOR IS TO RATIFY THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AWAIT.
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE DOES DOES
THIS ACTION ON THE LA --
BUT IT WOULD BE WOULD BE TO
MINUTES OF SENATOR MITCHELL'S
CHAIR CENTER NELSON AS THE
MEMBER TO FILL.
THE VACANCY SO THAT WE HAVE OUR
MEMBERS IN PLACE --
TO FOLLOW UP ON THE LA --
POSITION SO WE CAN TAKE A MOTION
ON BOTH ITEMS THREE AND FOUR
THANK YOUMADAM SECRETARY.
SENATORS GROVE GROVE I MINING.
MINING I ROSS.
ROSS I WILL CRY WILL GUY AT CAN
SIGN BACK INSIDE.
SO THAT LEAVES ITEMS TO THE
ADOPTION OF THE SESSION SCHEDULE.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN AND I OF
COURSE HAVE BEEN MADE AWARE THAT
THERE WAS A CONVERSATION.
AND SOME DIFFICULTY BETWEEN
ALIGNING THE SCHEDULES ARE FOR
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY.
ON A COUPLE OF I THINK MAYBE
JUST.
ONE ITEM IN PARTICULAR THE THE
CAESARS --
IT'S ON THE HOLIDAY CALENDAR SO
THE THIS CALENDAR.
IS CORRECT THEN YES.
OKAY BUT BEFORE I DO THIS MISTER
RALPH YOUR CONCERN WAS ON THIS
ITEM OR THE PREVIOUS ITEM.
HOLIDAY OKAY AS SOON AS WE WERE
IN THE STATE OF SO IF THE STATE
IS CLOSED ON MONDAY.
OUR DOORS TO THE BUILDING --
LOCKED.
WE CAN GET IN WITH PASS KEYS IN
A CODE.
BUT THE PUBLIC CAN'T GET IN AND
WE HAVE NO HVAC.
WE DO HAVE POWER LIGHT SO.
MY STAFF CAN REPORT CAN TURN ON
THE LIGHTS AND CONFIRM THE
COMPUTERS BUT WE WON'T HAVE ANY
PUBLIC -- ON
MONDAY.
AND WE WON'T HAVE ANY.
HEATING OR COOLING DEPENDING ON
THE TEMPERATURE.
WELL I'M A I'M A BIT
DISCONCERTED NOT TO HAVE BEEN
MADE AWARE OF THE SITUATION
BEFORE NOW --
THAT --
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING THAT
NEEDED TO BE WORKED OUT WITH THE
ASSEMBLY.
BEFORE WE APPROVE THE CALENDAR --
IS WE HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY --
TO I MEAN I CAN WORK AROUND AND
I JUST WANTED YOU TO KNOW WE CAN
WORK.
OTHER PLACES.
OR CAN SHIFT THE DAY --
PROBABLY OKAY AT WORK I JUST
WANTED YOU TO KNOW THAT THERE IS
AN ISSUE FOR THOSE OF US IN
STATE FACILITIES.
AWARE OF WHICH I AM AS WELL SO
ARE.
I APPRECIATE OUR I GUESS WE WILL
I WILL WORK WITH STAFF AS WE
LEAVE HERE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT.
BE THAT AS IT MAY I THEN THAT.
IS RELATED TO ITEM ONE WHICH
WE'VE ALREADY APPROVED BUT WE DO
NEED TO ADOPT THE SESSION
SCHEDULE WHICH I THINK WE ARE.
WE ARE FINE WITH THERE MIGHT BE
A LITTLE BIT OF A DO AN AROUND
JULY FOURTH BUT I THINK WE ARE
OKAY.
WITH WITH THIS CALENDAR.
AMOTION ON ITEM SO MOVED TO
THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY OF SENATORS
GROWTH.
GROVE I'D MINING MINING I ROSS.
ROSS I WILL ALL RIGHT WILL GUY
ATKINS I CAN SIGN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OTHER BUSINESS.
I THINK.
THAT IS IT WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN THE MEETING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE THANK YOU